dans notre série sur l'évocation des
événements de mai 68 c'est sans doute le
sujet le plus important que nous
abordons ce soir puisqu'il s'agit de
slogans des slogans de l'époque
les seuls qui soient vraiment rester
dans l'histoire comme il est interdit
d'interdire crs ss ou encore sous les
pavés la plage
gerrard almaz jean-françois cheveux
avaient dans la mare la france renaît
mais il faut se méfier de l'eau qui dort
printemps 68 la kermesse de la révolte
les murs fleuriste d'impertinence
hurlent leur provocation victoire de la
force des mots sur la force tout
quelques slogans sont inscrits dans la
mémoire collective mondiale surtout dans
les parages de la sorbonne est ce que
vous vous souvenez des seconds mai 68
pas du tout aucun nom
sous les pavés la plage joie qu'on l'ait
pas vu vol
face aux grilles est bien dans la gueule
lui qu'on regarde surpris quand saga du
sac
lorsque pas
pour idema prat
des gens
premiers jours de mai premier pavé des
lanceurs se font chercheurs mot d'ordre
et graffitis en tout genre le jus de
crâne devient talent au bistrot du coin
de copains se creuse à boules pour
trouver des idées l'un est publicitaire
en herbe
bernard fritsch l'autre futurs médecins
mais remarque use
ensemble ils griffonnent des formules
d'abord il y as d'herbe sous les pavés
et puis l'état sem voici d'ailleurs le
brouillon authentique de la version
définitive par son moteur de bons
acteurs pouze on avait une idée de
quelque chose qu'il fallait récupérer le
pavec ouest donc on est resté là ensuite
il ya eu tout ça défend du douar saint
michel avec les arbres abattus et puis
le fab en dessous il m'a dit il faut
mettre la plage la plage ça lui plaisait
c'était à coup c'est la grande époque du
club med quelques jours après à chaque
attaque gens à ce qu'elle tombe bien
j'ai écrit sous les pavés la plage et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la hyène
vient une bleue par subitement une
apprécié pour lui tout la forme pour
faire la césure giral houten virgule
bleus voilà et finalement c'est celui
qui l'a gardé et il a beaucoup aimé ce
truc qu'il a effectivement partout la
bienfaitrice emplois sur les murs sur
les murs partout de porto
des dizaines de slogans ou ou stupides
romantisme de la rébellion pu sceller
une sangle c est interdit d'interdire
et puis panne on travaille la jouissance
faites l'amour pas la guerre s'est
récemment
enfin marine comme le fait de le dire
c'est désagréable et crs slogan
iconoclaste par des fils de pub qui ne
le savaient pas encore mélange explosif
du choc des mots avec l'art poétique
jacques séguéla a commencé sa carrière
en mai 68 mais les le viol tu dois que
doit être un slogan à une poésie un
romantisme à une profondeur un lyrisme
que la publicité hobbit souvent et puis
ça n'était jamais et ventilent parce que
il est interdit d'interdire
c'est simple mais pas s'appeler sous les
pavés la plage c'est du cdu prévert
séguéla et sa bande ont signé ce tag
cours camarade le bio monde est derrière
toi
le parfum de mais demeure 68 a lancé des
bombes de mots restant d'actualité et
même il jouait pour noël 68 slogan à
l'appui
une maxime qui dit la barricade ferme la
rue mais ouvre la voie voici le pas des
briques